can you hear me all right sounds good
everyone here who knows
since eyes the schedule is so tight I'm
just going to start as a well first of
all thank you for uploading my talk
today and I try to cobble together a
short presentation at the beginning but
most of the part will be me trying to
assemble pieces of code that I know work
together and in a way that makes more
sense for you to understand it but
there's always the fallback of the full
working version so I have this is not
really live coding more like life copy
and pasting but I think it will help so
what I'm going to talk about is this
among other things short disclaimer I'm
currently working as a freelancer for
this company innovation but that's not
the reason I'm giving the talk it's just
the most of the products are pretty
awesome and this one especially it's
like one of the cheapest devices that
gives you some sort of button matrix
with colors on it it costs under 100
euros which sounds a lot for a piece of
plastic and LEDs but if you look at what
the competitors are doing or if you try
to build this by hand this is actually
relatively cheap and also it works very
reliable which is a good thing for music
instruments I guess so what this
technically is really just a field of
buttons and LEDs under it it's not even
velocity sensitive they are versions
that like to measure how hard you press
the buttons but in this case it's just
on and off and that's pretty cool for a
lot of musical applications but I always
feel like we are not using alternative
input methods enough and so I always try
to come up with interesting ideas
to do with it so how to talk to this
thing well meaty obviously like every
musical instrument really stands for a
musical instrument device interface some
of you may have heard to talk about this
for me before how many of you know
nothing about new MIDI okay a few hands
so the thing about media is that it's
really old media used to be about this
these are being plugs and the year is
1983 that is a long time ago how many of
you here are born after 1983 yeah that
always scares me a bit so the years 1983
and a few vendors of electronic
instruments you know the synthesizers
just became a thing and synthesizers
wanted to be you know you want to
connect synthesizers together and have
them play each other or whatnot and so
this was basically done by a few
companies coming together and agreeing
on a standard something that you don't
eat that often these days but it is I
mean probably web centers are pretty
close to what was happening here and
interestingly enough they kind of they
got out the one aspect and that's still
the relevant document which is kind of
fascinating what's not so relevant
anymore is like on the second page or so
there's electric circuitry how you
should build these reflex things to
isolate them correctly so that you
cannot destroy your instruments when
plugging things together nowadays mostly
MIDI runs over USB or just internally in
software but the protocol is still used
and the protocol is basically serial
data because back then that was like the
simplest thing that would possibly work
and
it it's really simple you only have two
types of well basically is bite by bite
and you only have two different types of
data
one is a command and one is a data bite
and a data stream on on any MIDI
interface regardless of you know one of
those old plugs or a USB interface looks
like this you have a command bite and
then data data data data data data data
data or maybe just data data and then
another command bite and that's the only
way how you can chunk come on luckily
you don't have to do that yourselves and
modern ID is but that's how it works
basically so speaking to this device
let's talk about briefly let's talk
briefly about output and what you see is
already kind of what you do with the web
MIDI API I'm going to talk about as soon
as you see the code but if it's
basically you're just sending bytes out
is this readable and the bottom or is it
too small okay so you send one command
and then data behind it and the specific
command here is 1:44 which is note on
and it's it's really it's really that
basic it's not like there's no
abstraction in the web MIDI API that
says okay note on is one point four you
just have to know that obviously there
are libraries that people wrote to make
it a little bit easier but for me I've
been doing MIDI programming for a long
time this feels home like this 144 yeah
I know that the second one is in this
case is the note on command the second
one this is different for different
commands so they are commands for like
twisting buttons and stuff but in this
case it's really just okay play a note
and the note here 24 these are just half
tones if someone knows what use our
music notation works these are just half
tones and the zero is basically the
lowest
and so 24 would probably be something
like these zero or something C zero and
the last one is velocity so how hot has
someone hit a keyboard or pull the
string or something if we want to talk
to the launch pad things are a little
bit different so the note on command
basically switches on one of those LEDs
below the buttons the second the note is
basically the position on the grid and
they did that in a very I don't know
clever way I guess where every row is so
zero would be top left and then 16 would
be the left in the next row because if
you've seen this there are actually nine
buttons on the row so if they couldn't
use eight as a divider so they use 16
and conveniently since we are talking
about seven bit numbers they go from 0
to 127 and 8 times 16 is 128 so it just
matches up so that's how they chose that
I guess so the last one is color and
talked about briefly about colors on
this thing because they are little bit
special so first of all we can only have
127 different colors originally right
because we only have PC of 7 bit so
that's a bummer if you want to do RGB
LEDs because then you have to kind of
narrow down the color space to get into
that and I actually didn't look at how
the larger launch pads do that but in
this case since this is a chief Hardware
it works a little bit different in that
they are not RGB LEDs that can do the
full color spectrum but they are red
green LEDs and red and green LEDs are
like one of the first types of LEDs
invented they have really really cheap
and you can get them in this specific
combination red green LEDs are a thing
so they're not two LEDs per button this
is actually one but with combined
circuitry for red and green
and if you kind of modulate the
intensity of red and green you get to
something like this which is a weird
spectrum between red and green and
yellow and amber and orange somewhere in
there but it's it's slightly problematic
to use all the different colors
especially ones that are close together
if you want to kind of convey meaning
because they are sometimes the
calibration on the LEDs is a little bit
off so you have to be careful with that
I really like that phrase and in the
documentation readers who are versed in
the manipulation of binary will have
worked out really like that phrase so
how does input work well as you might
think they just send note on the note
offs and for in the web media API you
would connect an event handler to the
input ports I'm going to show you how
that works later on and then the actual
thing is like if you press a button you
get a note on event and if you release a
button you get a note of event which is
not technically correct in the sense
that you actually get a note off command
but it is within the specs that you can
just send a note on command with
velocity zero because back in the days
you know microcontrollers were very slow
and so they thought well probably it's
easier for them to do it that way and
novation thought well this is a cheap
microcontroller let's do it the same way
so you just get these two signals and 24
I think I checked it's like the last
button on the second row I guess so
let's talk about minesweeper and you all
know who doesn't know what mines meat
cleaver is okay that's good so there are
a few UI challenges if you want to port
this to a device like this this is the
actual minesweeper version I'm using if
you're
you're familiar with minesweeper your
you will notice that it's actually 8x8
and I think the original minesweeper the
small grid is 9 by 9 or something but
for this case it's really good because
we have 8x8 button and the first
challenge is this because like I told
you colors are really hard to
distinguish so if I want to build
something where you can actually check
how many a adjacent of mines there are
and it's really important to play
minesweeper then I need to come up with
a mechanism that works better than just
displaying color so we'll come to that
later the second challenge is yeah you
have to flag fields for mine right and
how do you normally do that in mine
sweeper right click correct so there is
no like there button how do I do a right
click and so yeah I could use a key on
the keyboard that's kind of stupid and
my first approach was to simply use one
of the extra buttons and make it so that
I press it and then press the other
thing what I turns out that it's a
little bit the button is a little bit
too unreliable for that to work and so
more often than not I would press it and
then hit it and then it would reveal the
field and guess what there's a bomb
underneath it or mine and then
everything blows up and I was kind of
kind of frustrated by that so I took
another approach and just make it like
different make it so like they are
different different modes so yeah let's
go this will be
for we need to realign this a little bit
so you can see it so I do have a camera
here for later on let's start with this
is way too small this good so let's
start with the very basics of how you
would start interacting with the web
media API by the way I didn't talk about
this web media API currently only works
in chromium browsers there is a team
working at the at Mozilla to implement
it I have no idea what Apple is doing
and I know signals from Microsoft
yet I think and so yeah we're working
for the Firefox thing but the chromium
interestingly enough also works on
Android devices so you can plug if you
have an Android device where you can
actually plug use II devices into it
that actually works with the launchpad
as well kind of cool
so the init MIDI function at this point
is only called in an onload handler and
then you do navigate a request MIDI
access and it's modern API so it uses
promises as promising a kibosh yeah it
was issues with keyShot so and then you
would you need to find your media
devices they are just enumerated and
some sort of array it's not a real array
as usual when you're dealing with arrays
from internal API so some reason they
always come up with new ways of
disguising errors or something else and
you would do a for each on it and then
you can check the name and that's
basically the only way how you can
distinguish devices so this one goes for
Launchpad mini if you have another
Launchpad you would probably and you
want to use both you would probably do
some sort of regex
on that which is something for example
we also do for the device I'm working
with in my Novation project because
sometimes also
windows tend to kind of enumerate them
and say okay launchpad mini one
launchpad menu - even if there's only
one connected and you have to deal with
that and I'm gonna you know I'm going to
show you the the minesweeper stuff in a
second but what you notice here is I'm
just using global variables because
that's the coding style used in the
original minesweeper implementation
that's obviously not how you would want
to do that but for short demo like this
this is okay so I'm detecting inputs and
outputs set variables and then yeah I
need to in at the display so let's do
that the function is not here so let's
get that like I said copy and paste
there you go and what this does is it
sets a few messages that are also
documented in in the documentation so it
sends out a reset be 0 is 176 by the way
that's a control change another type of
message and then I use something to to
make this LED blink which is a special
mode a flashing mode that you have to
activate and then I just send to note on
messages to to set these to led to these
two LEDs so that you know that I have a
special meaning
let me check I think I need to change
this no okay so this is how the H how
the how the webpage currently works and
you can actually can play that Wow
that's raw but nothing happens right now
on the launchpad so let's go forward so
we entered the display that's fine but
actually it should be blank is not
happening
that's interesting wrong here no all
right right because obviously this is
this is not mean you sent note on that's
not fine as well let's get that quickly
it's really really simple it's just a
convenient function all the checks if
the media is available that work now no
it doesn't what does it give it okay if
this goes on like this again I'm going
to fall back to the full version might
be worth checking might be worth oh yeah
I know you're right guess I try to hack
it in a way that I didn't have to like
monkey patch the original implementation
so ah there you go
blank this way wonderful where yeah
where does the shadows come from
interesting okay anyway so we have that
and then let in the next step let's add
the the input handler here so that's how
you you know you know add eventlistener
that's pretty standard stuff so we just
need the media input handler let's get
that over this one and there you can see
like how this stuff sort of work so you
get a data part in the event and it it
just contains an array it's a type area
of you in eight that will just contain
the the data sent over and so I'm just
ignoring everything that is not a node
on here I try to figure out the row and
column of the button that gets pressed
and then I have two two handlers
and the important one is the note unhand
ler and that one going to copy over
that's a little bit more complicated
because it does a lot of different
things but one thing it does and that
like where functionality goes in is this
part so they are there's a click square
function in the original like the
original looked like this is really
old-school JavaScript and there's a
proper where is it like this is the full
minesweeper implementation and there's a
click square thing that's just an event
handler that's on every element on on
the webpage and I'm just calling that
from from my function to be able to not
or to to not having to monkey patch the
other software and so basically I'm
clicking the square so this should this
should now actually work I think did I
yeah so let's load this again and now so
you see that I hit the button nothing is
displayed because we didn't handle that
yet but you can see that I can already
expose phew so that's cool and you know
all I all I do here is I take the the
row and column and then I though the way
the original game handles the internal
data is just using 64 length arrays and
you know basically every row eight eight
bytes of that or eight pieces of that
and so to get the actual position you
just take the row multiply it by 8 and
then at the column oh and the important
part is this one this is a normal click
exactly and send
let's try to get this play on and set
that's a little bit more complicated
because again I didn't want to I didn't
want to really patch around and the
other thing and I did a very stupid
thing which is just overwrite it
override the function it's pointless
probably and that's basically the
longest function it's a little bit hard
to go through that but we're trying it
basically mirrors the original set
square function and instead of setting
classes and changing the contents of
cells it sends MIDI notes and if I do
that actually nothing happens
yay why is that that is a bummer okay
that's a help function I wrote that
needs to go in this well Oh
so that's just you know going from the
yeah exactly so this is I showed you the
documentation and I just try to figure
out some some color values that make
sense and I'm just using the just adding
the velocity value so I need to put that
in here as well
there you have it
and you can already see like the yellow
tone something may have to do with the
lighting in this room but they they kind
of look all different even though I'm
sending the same value to all field so
that that's kind of a bummer but yeah
great
but you can now start playing the game
which is kind of fun but for example
what we didn't handle did we know what
we didn't handle yet is flagging for
example that was obvious so let's do
that
where was I so like I mean this is
looking at this this doesn't even make
sense if you don't know what the
original code does but you have you have
an array which gives you the exposed
elements and then there's another array
which gives you the adjacent values and
you basically go through all the go you
basically go through all the
possibilities and then set the right
color so exactly so in this case here
I'm checking on the note on handler I'm
checking that the column I'm the button
was pressed on it's smaller than eight
because the the 8th column is like my
command column and so I have this this
other thing here
and if it's row six that's the that's
the Jeep why you don't see the they're
actually letters makes it the yellow one
this place if you resist the the playing
field and click smiley was like that's a
bit weird but that's how the original
game works for as well right and that's
a function in the original
implementation so the other one is road
seven I'm just toggling the flag mode
and then sending a note to it so that
that you actually see this blinking
right so I can toggle flag mode
oh come on give me something to work
with you and I can now switch this on
and flag it switch it off again and play
on so that's pretty obviously you're
mine you agree so that works and now
let's do the last thing which is a way
to show how many adjacent buttons are
there and that that's that's the fun
part these are just two functions going
to copy over as well and what this does
is it sends control changes because for
some reason the row on the top here is
switch on and off by control changes and
I'm just going through the adjacent the
number of adjacent fields here and
switch on the top row so that if you hit
the button you can actually see how many
mines are adjacent to it so of course on
YouTube and you know just a function to
to deactivate that display as well
but that one and then there's where's
the off handler I didn't include that so
now you know my code better than me
maybe ah come on
yeah exactly let's include that one well
somewhere to pull it in there is totally
irrelevant and then I need to then I
need to activate it here and now you now
it's basically done if I for example hit
this button you see that there's only
one mine so I can flag this one and
since this is also one I can also flag
this one this is also one you know how
to play minesweeper right and one thing
like how late is it are we almost done
okay so these are now about 160 lines of
code of relatively well relatively well
commented code I'm pretty sure I could
write it in a more compact fashion but
then you wouldn't understand the thing
it's actually online at pad no offside
yes
pants we birthday it is so if you have a
launchpad
she probably haven't you can actually
play it there but you can actually also
just play some screen credits to who
Andrew the barrel who wrote the original
implementation probably in I don't know
1995 or something and it was for me it
was really fun to just try to figure out
how to hack this in there without
actually without actually touching the
ill code and as you can see it's
relatively simple to just you know send
me data over here and now I'm going to
show you one last thing and that is the
implementation from this morning
which is just an array and I know it's
hard to see but this is the J and this
is the s and then I'm just sending out
you know I'm just activating the output
and then I'm just sending out this array
very very simply by copying over some
code and if I activate that
you get the logo so so what can we do
with that apart from playing minesweeper
and I'm going to sit outside if you want
to play it on the launch pad I think
it's a pretty cool experience just come
over and hit me up on that if you want
to like what can we do with that one
thing that I find pretty cool is that
Adam my editor is actually building on
chromium and I think the web media API
works there so what about using this for
some additional keyboard shortcuts I
mean there are 64 plus 16 on these or
display test results from your unit test
runs or something and then you can just
hit a red button and go to the file and
position of where the error is stuff
like that it doesn't make a lot of sense
but it's actually pretty fun to play
with and MIDI communications is so fast
that it doesn't even matter if you I
mean Adams already not so fast but
probably that doesn't matter as much so
thank you very much for listening if you
have any questions like I said I'll be
sitting outside thank
[Applause]